welcome to the developmental biology
playlist in this video we are going to
look at the second week of embryonic
development in humans
we are going to focus on the key events
that happens in the second week
and the first and foremost event
that happens in the second week is the
implantation of the blastocyst
before jumping into details let us recap
what happened in the first week of
embryonic development
everything started with the
fertilization event which leads to the
production of
zygote
zygote divides and forms two cell stage
four cell stage eight cell stage
eventually becomes the morula
which has a mulberry-like appearance and
has 16 blasphemers approximately
eventually the morula would give rise to
blastocyst
and this is around six to seven days
of the post-fertilization
let's say we are around seven days
and in this stage
the blastocyst would slowly move towards
the uterine cavity
and ultimately it would attach
to the uterine wall
at this point of time blastocyst has two
different cellular organizations
the outer layer is known as trophoblast
the inner layer is known as embryoblast
which has
another name known as inner cell mass
the cells of the inner cell mass are
actually pluripotent stem cells
that mean it can give rise to different
cell types
eventually the inner cell mass would
become the embryo
now at day eight trophoblasts which was
the outer layer further differentiates
now it becomes
cytotrophoblast
and the synthesiotrophoblast
cytotrophic cells play important role in
terms of
embedding the embryo in the uterus
the cytotrophoglost
is also considered to be stem cells
they can diversify into different
lineages
like fusion lineage like invasive
lineage
it's also important to understand this
cytotrophoblast cells fuse with each
other
and form the synthetrophoblast
since issue trophoblasts are really
important in terms of maternal gas
exchange
nutrient exchange and immunological and
metabolic functions
it's the synthetrophoblas
that creates the first connection
between the mother and the developing
embryo before even formation of the
placenta
at day eight the inner cell mass also
diversified
and now it's known as the bilaminar
embryonic disc
it has two layers
one the hypoblast the second is the ap
blast
hypoblast is comprising of
cells which are cuboidal in nature
and inside the epiblast the amniotic
cavities start forming
the epiblast cells are columnar in
nature whereas hypoblast cells are
cuboidal in nature at day eight we can
appreciate
heterogeneity starts appearing from a
homogeneous cell pool at least in terms
of their morphology we can appreciate
the heterogeny heterogeneity forming
now at day 10
there are further development
cells of the hypoblast
move
and migrate
it forms
the primitive york sac
also lacuna starts appearing in the
synthetiotrophoblast
now this lacuna would eventually form an
intricate network known as lacunar
network
by the day by the end of day 10
we can completely understand
the blastocyst has embedded completely
in the endometrium
the cytotrophic secretes specific
proteolytic enzymes that break down the
extracellular matrix of the endometrium
and allow the embryo to burrow deep
inside the endometrium
now projections of the
synthetiotrophoblast pull the embryo
inside the endometrium until and unless
it is fully covered with the endometrial
epithelium
this snapshot shows you that how the
embryo is burrowing deep in the
endometrium by the day 10
at day 12 further development happens
the lacunar network so lacuna becomes
more
prominent
and it invades the maternal sinusoids
now it ruptures the maternal sinusoids
that leads
to
that that leads to the blood
connection between the embryo and the
mother
so this is the first time when maternal
blood
is
connecting with the embryo
now
inside the cytotrophoblast
and outside the hypoblast
there is formation of the extra
embryonic mesoderm
slit appears in this extra embryonic
mesoderm eventually
and it ultimately forms the chorionic
cavity
and there is a portion of extra
embryonic mesoderm that holds the inner
part of the embryo and this is known as
the primitive stock which is otherwise
known as the future umbilical cord
so in this video we can appreciate how
the developing blastocyst has implanted
in the endometrium and slightly it has
grown in size
and
intricate lacunar network has formed
that means the connection between mother
and the embryo has been established
by the second week of development
nutrient exchange gas exchange
everything has started by these time
point
in subsequent videos we'll look at how
gastrulation process occurs
by the way if you want the video flash
card of this topic you can find it in my
community post if you like this video
give it a quick thumbs up don't forget
to like share and subscribe
do let me know you
do let me know in the comment how you
like my videos if you wish to follow me
on social media all my links are
provided in the description
you can click on the links and get
connected to me in the social media see
you in the next video